I mean New Orleans swagger exists and it
has everything to do with its food
people are incredibly proud of this idea
that the food in New Orleans is more
delicious than it is anywhere else it
props the city up the food of New
Orleans is a point of pride bordering on
obsession nowhere else will you find
this melting pot of French Spanish
African Native American and Caribbean
flavor all mixed up adding to the mixed
Nola's Vietnamese community has brought
their national sandwiches upon me to
po-boy country now the lines are
blurring in sandwiches like this so what
do you get when you mash up the
Mississippi Delta and the Mekong Delta
I'm gonna eat my way to an answer
directly after the Vietnam War there was
a large influx of Vietnamese to South
Louisiana New Orleans and really all the
Gulf Coast really stepped up in
welcoming refugees there were all these
parallels river deltas brackish water
seafood similar growing seasons we all
grew up eating whole boys and then later
grew up eating a lot of bun meat you
know you have to bond me and the po-boy
which are these kind of like kissing
cousins a po-boy is our southern version
of guests of like a sub it's a sandwich
built on a long piece of French bread
it's a specific kind of New Orleans
style French bread traditionally bun
meat have a mayonnaise on it or an IO a
fresh cucumber jalapeno pickled carrot
mint cilantro the original Vietnamese
restaurants that were serving Bon me
have used the po-boy to sell their pon
me so that on the menu they would call
their sandwiches Vietnamese boys because
of that similarity
[Music]
before we get into how people are mixing
and matching the bond me and the po-boy
sandwiches I got to check out my old
friend a New Orleans legend currency
he's gonna get into the foundation the
po-boy the reason there's a call it's
called a pull was because the French
bread was easier to get it's filling you
know so there's the science behind this
sandwich is pretty affordable so it was
a po-boy because the poor boys could
afford and look at Simple Minds is you
know like I slide up you might think I'm
about to get some elaborate big money
sandwich but this this is it this is a
quality piece of catfish okay
Friday at Cash knit you got mayonnaise
you got pickles you got a whopper in the
seafood plant that's good the best thing
about the po-boy is you can do it any
kind of way it's like a Chevy
Funkmaster Flex he's like 65 and fathers
but he likes something with big wheels
on them I like them as lowriders so a
po-boy is like a Chevy and you can do
however you want but it's still the chef
I'm originally from Chicago they have
hot beef sandwiches in Chicago right
that's a big thing I don't really eat
those because I feel like that's almost
something that tourists eat
whereas here in New Orleans po-boy
you're eating hopeless yes like what are
you raised on that beef sandwich I was
just a thing that everybody talked about
yeah no right we don't talk about this
that he's raised on there's french bread
in your house and if everybody's gone
and you're 10 years old you still know
how to work the microwave and there's
nothing to take the catfish you're mine
fried last night and put it you know you
grew up with that gets in your house
yeah you don't recognize how unusual
that is oh not a loaf uh well I was
unique you know I always felt like it my
whole city is shredded down unique we're
not no New Orleanians are resilient
wouldn't our sandwich be the po-boy come
on we go through a lot we've been
through a lot in there the [ __ ]
tornado like a couple weeks ago this
[ __ ] is off you see all that done all
these people are solidly housing [ __ ]
again what are you going to do you know
get a po-boy currency is clearly about
that po-boy life but growing up with
Vietnamese American classmates
he ate Vaughn me sandwiches at friends
houses without even knowing it not far
from where currency grew up is the
Vietnamese neighborhood of a lodge Leste
that's where my friend Chi helps run the
veggie farmers co-op both the fresh
produce and the bonhomie from this
community have become staples throughout
the city
this urban farm was started by you guys
to find jobs for the Vietnamese
community after the BP oil spill maybe
they were fishing before that now
they're farming the connective tissue is
still food you speak to what food means
for this community has always been
something that they've had in their
blood basically to survive in a new
place in a new community and they've
built that out over 40 years here Asian
Americans and Asian immigrants a lot of
times will operate in isolation from the
rest of America in the aftermath of
Katrina with the redevelopment plans the
city didn't really even realize that the
community out here had come back in
large numbers we organized together
young and old to shut down the landfill
that was put here after Katrina because
they figured oh you know like these
Americans they won't say anything
everyone now recognizes this is the
powerful community the interesting thing
is the food that you guys are growing or
fishing in New Orleans is not just for
the Vietnamese who me at this point
it's also the way that you guys interact
with the larger community of New Orleans
we do farmers markets we sell to
restaurants such as mofos with John Besh
restaurants Donald link restaurants you
see like so many more Vietnamese
restaurants in the city I think within
the last 10 years it's exploded
you also mentioned a bakery that's very
important to the community what is that
don't fool as the bread that every funny
place influence basically uses we eat
there yes let's go
[Music]
this bread is kind of the most famous
part of this community it's a brand name
you know people come from over the
cities come here for the bread what is
it about it that everybody's sort of
latching on to I think like if you're
able to like eat it like try one you you
see like if the inside is just like it
just melts in your mouth
now the bread itself that's here it's
it's so signature to dunk finally but ho
boy shops are now sort of adopting it
it's just good to see that they're
different ways to make a po-boy or there
are different ways to make like me and
there's ways to like marry the two
cultures as well in New Orleans like
food is a hue unifier you know like if
you can cook if the food is good people
will flock to it it's evident how
important the dumpling bakery and
restaurant is to the Vietnamese
community in New Orleans but this bread
is spreading all around New Orleans
people are taking the same by me bread
and kind of remix in it and making it
their own we gotta go find that I know
we're here for lunch but we're at a gas
station and I see a po-boy shop over
there so what's going on in Louisiana
gas stations have the best food but
attached to this gas station is bond me
boys the in bond me Bo is not only do
they serve on me they serve all boys the
only place I know of where both
sandwiches can exist as their size
perfect harmony so we have two sides of
the menu on me
po boys frequent customers come in here
and mix and match yeah soft shell since
season right now let's get soft-shell
crab and you want it would you like that
oh no I would have more it's an edge
well let's get it on funding
Peter Wynn is the owner and Peter's mom
wanted to open a po-boy shop he argued
for Vietnamese restaurant specifically
for a bawd me restaurant everybody
smells pool ways over here so I really
want to incorporate our Vietnamese side
and really nobody is really taking about
me to the next level so I have people
that come in and actually get everything
that goes on up on me on a 10-inch
po-boy and then have people that want
something like a hot sausage patty on
upon me dressed with our vegetables
besides what we have here I found me
boys are there other businesses there
actually be serve mashups michael colada
left the premier restaurant the city
august to open his own place called mo
felt should you be messing with the
original po-boy I mean you're starting
fist fights if you're gonna use red for
your po boys radition aliy you're gonna
use a lot in heimer or if you're gonna
make by me you're gonna use don't follow
me we work to make sort of a hybrid
where it's a little bit lighter on the
inside it's still nice and crunchy on
the outside the sandwich is there
they're not po boys they're not bond me
but they really resemble the two I love
the fresh flavors of upon me the mint
the cilantro the pickles but I love the
proteins that I grew up with which is
the shrimp the oysters the hot sausage
it's one of the greatest things about
New Orleans is that we assimilate all
cultures
[Music]
New Orleans is a Creole city and that
word Creole originally just meant mashup
it meant people from someplace else and
some other people maybe from someplace
else and they come here and they make
new people
New Orleans is proud of their Vietnamese
community and defeating these people are
like super proud to be like in New
Orleans they're a huge part of our
infrastructure and their food has become
a huge part of our cuisine I think the
Vietnamese popoyo it's just a sandwich
but I think it's an important chapter in
the modern story of New Orleans food it
is the one dish that I think you can
point to to demonstrate to an outsider
that this food isn't static that it
isn't just Jambo Lyon gumbo that it has
always evolved and it continues to
evolve you know that says a lot you know
for a sandwich
[Music]